mark is in Orlando Florida hey Mark how
are you doing good new better than I
deserve what's up okay so my girlfriend
and I have been together for about three
years
we're very young and we would like to
move on and move forward in our lives
and get married and move in together
good we don't know for financially
stable though and we will want to be
smart about it financially smart how old
are you 21 okay and what do you make
about 30 at 35 a year and what's your
career right now I'm just a warehouse
worker okay so what's your plan
I got sure I don't know if we should go
and no no wonder her career plan oh
great plan sorry no pretend like some
young man who's a sharp young guy who's
working in a warehouse is 21 just walked
into your house and one to marry your
daughter yeah what would you tell him I
don't want to know what his dadgum plan
is right yes sir are you gonna take care
of this girl I would love to take care
of her I can't I know I'm giving you a
hard time brother okay but if you'll see
if you'll think about it that way it
forces you to think about your long-term
prospects which is as her dad that's
what he'd be looking at right he'd be
saying okay this guy's a sharp young
dude he's not making anything right now
he's working in a warehouse but wait but
he's got really got a really good career
path he's got a plan and it's gonna work
out I mean by the time he's 31 what are
you gonna be doing you know so I'm more
concerned about that I think you can
make it on 35 does she have a job she's
in school and doing a part-time job at a
restaurant when does she graduate from
school she has about another year and a
half to two years okay and what would
her degree be in she's teaching okay and
who's paying for her school right now
her and her parents okay all right would
they continue that and she could
completely be a teacher while you're
married I think they would yeah I'm
pretty cool with it okay
that's good so you could go ahead and
get married and you'd have her part-time
income and your $35,000 income knowing
that in a year 18 months she's gonna be
a teacher and your household incomes
going to more than double you'd be
making over 70 a couple close to 80
thousand depending on what she's
teaching where she's teaching and all
that kind of stuff right but with a
teaching certificate in Florida she'll
she'll make good money and then you've
got better prospects because you're
gonna start thinking about what you want
to be when you're 31 and start taking
the steps to be that so that when you're
41 you're also a better one and 51
you're a rich one wait does that make
sense okay yeah so I think you've got
the stuff to get married but I'm more
concerned about where you're going than
where you are today to answer the
question of are you ready for marriage
and I think you are you're sharp young
guy and obviously she's doing she's got
a great career crack there so you know
what I would want you to answer for your
own satisfaction I was poking at you and
saying let's pretend it's our dad right
but for your own satisfaction what do
you want to do where are you going
cuz let me tell you if you aim at
nothing you'll hit it every time you'll
be a 31 year old warehouse worker and
you don't want to die there's nothing
wrong there's no shame in being a
warehouse worker but you want to be
growing and evolving right yeah you
wanna be something better you know I
want you to own the freakin warehouse
okay that's how I would look at it and
if you got all that kind of talked
through and so forth then you got a game
plan see my goal was I was gonna be rich
in real estate when I was your age
that's what I wanted to do I was dating
my wife I was 21 I was so broke I
couldn't pay attention I had a dollar
sixteen in my checking account I'm
driving along on our second date in a
Monte Carlo that had 250,000 miles the
third engine and the second transmission
had been hit on every side this car was
a piece of crap we're driving along on
her second date and I'm telling her how
I'm gonna be a millionaire in real
estate one day and as we as I said that
we went across a railroad track the
muffler fell off my car so where I was
right then was not indicative of where I
was going
because if anybody looked at where I was
right there there was no evidence to say
I was going to be anybody but you got to
be aiming at something man
that's what you got to be doing this is
the Dave Ramsey show